[Music]
Rachel Louis look at you
[Music]
mr. funding bodies it's chaos out there
[Music]
this house is being requisitioned by the
British government
this is your house I love you hub
illumise hello Morgan
please come inside it's my wife
[Music]
my daughter and I will stay out of your
way until we move to the camp what if we
let them stay warden
you mean live with him it may not be an
outward show of hatred but is there
below the surface during the war did you
ever hope for a German victory did the
bombing affect the health of you and
your family it affected the health of my
wife she died in the firestorm I'm so
sorry you didn't tell me what I was
walking into this isn't how it was
supposed to be none of us is how it is
supposed to be please don't go I have a
job to do
[Music]
we're going to spy on a girl the least
you could do is pay a compliment yes of
course
[Music]
something's changed be careful that's
all they don't like us
I don't feel that I could be happy like
come with me this is what you wanted
new beginnings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you